in the northern syrian town of kamishli
this week
three car bombs in a single day at least
five people died
more than 20 were injured for the kurds
who've spent half a decade fighting isis
on the west's behalf
there is no doubt this was the work of
islamic state sleeper cells
the organization is making a comeback
that threatens us all
general maslum kabani is the most senior
official in this kurdish region of syria
an ally of the west and a man who now
feels let down
he told sky news that turkey's recent
incursion into the area
is undoing everything he and the western
coalition have achieved
the danger of the resurgence of isis is
very big and it's a serious danger
i think there are many people who don't
know this but it's true the turkish
aggression
opened the space and provided hope for
isis members
and the cities that turkey entered will
be a base for isis to reform itself
and he made an extraordinary allegation
against a nato member country
he claimed that not only was turkey
allowing isis to return
it is encouraging it so this is a very
serious
allegation you're suggesting that a nato
member
is actively encouraging isis to return
to an area
that you and the coalition removed them
from is that right eddie
yes it's a big allegation and there's
evidence of it
many people know it not just isis
members but also former members
of al-nusra and al-qaeda fighters who we
fought against in 2013
and 2014. the turkish government says
such claims are preposterous
but footage like this filmed in northern
syria is say the kurds proof
that islamist jihadists are fighting
alongside the turkish army
and in the middle of all the fighting
are the prisoners of the islamic state
held by kurdish guards who admit they
can't do this for much longer
what's your message to the governments
of europe
we repeatedly told them they have two
choices to take back their prisoners and
put them on trial
if they can do so or to set up an
international court here
because we can't hold them forever has
either of those
plans got any traction
so is there a risk that we could see
further
isis spectacular attacks uh in the west
as a consequence of
inaction indecision by the west
in your region this is possible
it's one of the expected things that may
happen in the future
we don't know the fate of these
prisoners in syria and the balance here
has changed
as we spoke helicopters outside
the americans he told me they didn't
really leave as donald trump had claimed
but their mission here now is confused
and while it is isis he says is
reforming
mark stone sky news in syria